yeah just found out i'm gonna do um
driving with mario andretti one of the
most famous drivers man
signing a life away baby
i've never done anything like this i've
been on the gravatron and uh
you know that kind of deal
never been with anybody this famous
before the guy that usually takes me to
the airport he smokes a lot of
cigarettes but he's a good guy mike
[Music]
yeah somebody said we're gonna go almost
200 miles an hour man 1 15 the speed of
sound
[Music]
it's the nicest uber i've ever gotten in
my life
[Music]
i wish we were going backwards let all
the blood flow down
[Music]
so
oh man beats going to a chiropractor
that was crazy man
that's the closest i ever been to
another man doing anything like that
yeah in the city everything goes by so
fast man that dude's a getaway driver oh
i'm happy to be alive you know
it's really fun man
the scary parts were the turns and then
imagine if anybody else
[Music]
the whole thing just blew my mind man
it's like a disney world for like people
that love gasoline you know it's fast
it's scary i wish we could have driven
past some chicks
[Music]
you